this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday the 20th of
February the joint is brought to you by
manscape listen if you're still using
ball trimmer on your face listen up you
[__] Savages I love you manscape just
announced a brand new beard edger the
beard hedge is cordless it's waterproof
and you can shave anywhere and it gives
you 20 different hair cutting lengths
for Mr Clean to Grizzly Adams to
everything in between plus manscape is
thrown in there especially formulated
beard shampoo and conditioner which I'm
going to give to Lee designed to
moisture reduce ingrown hairs and
replace natural oils impress your lady
when you finish off with manscapes beard
oil and beard bomb forget about it she's
gonna [__] kiss you to death and
since manscape wants you to have all the
tools for the job that's thrown in a
beard brush a comb and scissors to make
you look tipped top Magoo so do me a
favor I'm Gonna Get You 20 off and free
shipping that's big with code Diaz Diaz
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use code Diaz
d-i-a-z the joint is also brought to you
by steps.com listen get ahead of the
competition by using stamps.com
stamps.com lets you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office if it's ready to go
in minutes you understand me I've been
with stamps.com for over 10 years my
wife still uses them tremendous with
stamps you could easily schedule pickup
and compare carriers and weights with a
kick of the click of the button print
postage whatever you do business all you
need is a computer and a printer
stamps.com even sends you a free scale
so you'll have everything you need to
get the party started set up your small
business large business for Success when
you get started with stamps.com today
Monday sign up with promo code Joey for
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code Joey [__] the joint is
also brought to you by one of my
personal favorites liquid IV stay
hydrated no matter what's going on
Lincoln IV is very easy to use one stick
of liquid IV hydrates two times faster
than water and has five five essential
vitamins the concord grape tremendous
the strawberry tremendous the sour apple
tremendous oh my God they got so many
fruit flavors you'll lose your mind that
gluten-free dairy-free soy free liquid
IV contained three times the
electrolytes of traditional sport drinks
so get the party started today you could
grab liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or Uncle Joe is going to give you
20 off when you go to liquid ib.com and
use code Joey to check out again that's
liquid iv.com use code Joey at checkout
that's 20 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code Joey at liquid iv.com now
without further Ado I'm here with Lee to
drop some knowledge on you [__]
on a Monday morning
all right
hey how you doing good morning
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
[__] it's Monday the 20th of
February Uncle Joey here with my main
man lee Syed what up celebrating my 60th
[__] birthday it was phenomenal we
ate mushrooms we went bowling we [__]
went to Carvel we did it all you
understand me we did it all Lee's
basically recovering he had to come over
and drink a liquid IV this morning that
saved me
what's that oh yeah they have my Target
but I got them cheaper if you go to
liquid iv.com forget about it I save you
25 [__] percent check but those
things will save your life when you're
stoned you know I didn't want to talk
about that because liquid IV is a great
company but if you got one too many
bungs in here one too many edible
aluminum or one too many chocolate
mushrooms or just mushrooms all together
and maybe ate some badass last night
liquid IV got you you understand me all
of the above all of the above you wake
up with that pubic dry mouth
you spit the hands out you popping a
[__] pina colada liquid IV 16 ounces
of water who the [__] is better than you
you understand me but no it was great we
had a it's been a [__] wild ride
because last week I wasn't sad about it
it was just a number to me
but it really is like a [__] major
thing like yeah 60 like is like
and the funny thing is guys where did it
go
something funny and I was thinking about
it you said like you felt like you were
in your 20s still
okay like I think about I don't feel any
different than I did when I was 18.
you know listen man you you wake up in
the morning feeling pretty [__] good
I had bad days and I got good days you
know tomorrow is going to be a bad day
because I went to two jiu jitsu's and
two lips in four days that's not what I
should be doing
so the next two days I'm gonna be
[__] hurting when we were younger
you know I could run all [__] day
seven days a week and not even have
maybe get a splinter from jumping a
fence or something like that you know
I mean those differences right what
about mentally though like I don't feel
any different mentally
well you're [__] 30 you shouldn't be
there I don't know I still feel like
like if you told me I was 18. even if
you even if you're [__] [__] I
give you one of these Edibles you're
gonna feel good about yourself within
three or four minutes you know it's a no
[__] brain I mean but no all
I feel better now than I did in my 40s
because I was waking up on cocaine right
that's a horrible horrible feeling in
the morning to wake up and your body
feels like you get a little [__]
electrical shocks and [__] you know
liquid IV couldn't help that [__] no not
the electrical shocks look what IV can
do a lot but but man no
you know now I've been really taking
care of myself yeah
you know when you go on the road guys
and I and I don't think about it then
you don't think about it while you're
doing it but I'm going to give you a
short [__] you do there was a time
when we did the morning podcast
we got up at 6 5 45 yeah it started at
six
4 45 and then we uh
and then I'd have to fly and then early
on Thursday morning or oh yeah Thursday
morning I'm leaving six and then
Friday I'd have to do radio
and then sadly you do two shows at the
club you get out of that one you set the
alarm for four because again when you're
20 you don't need to sleep
like when I went on the road with Joe
and Ari and Duncan there was no sleep
we'd finished the two shows and hang out
in the hotel lobby till because why
sleep it's four hours why sleep what a
waste of time well when you get older
you need those four hours and even those
four hours you know
this is why I can't stand connecting
flights in the morning I don't mind
taking a connecting flight out
but in when you're coming back you just
work five days you're walking on [__]
you know and I still remember two
distinct airports number one is Chicago
when you got two three hours of sleep
and you got to fly through Chicago and
connect
it's a [__] you know and Chicago's
always your plane lands in another city
where the gate is yeah you know what I'm
saying so you got a Sprint there and
[__] that's one situation but I think
the toughest airport for me to ever
connect through was Detroit that that
one's terrible I did that Detroit it's
not that it's terrible it's a beautiful
airport and it's pretty modern it's got
like this avant-garde art has a train up
top there's a train up top but when you
walk underneath yeah and you got to go
to the avant-garde thing and you on and
you're on 10 hours of sleep plus six
shows plus three early mornings you in
the Twilight Zone
and you don't know how really close you
are as a human being can just dying
you really don't your body is wiped the
[__] out and now you're gonna get on
another plane
whatever three hours from Detroit and
I'm not complaining here but I'm just
giving you the reality these are the
biggest differences I saw thank God I
was smart enough as I got older to force
myself
to go to sleep on Saturday nights
that's where the Edibles and the Xanax
came in because I could not take a
chance and not fall asleep now think
about this think about eating his Xanax
and waking up
three hours later you're still pretty
much ain't it you're done you're done
and you're walking through an airport
you know that's why when I talk to
comedians a lot of them I left my wallet
at the airport I left my belt at the
airport because you're [__] a sleep
guy well and because you didn't even
really fully paint the picture when we
started the podcast it was Monday
Wednesday started at six
so it was Sunday night you weren't and
Sunday you were just coming back from
the road so you weren't sleeping Sunday
night Monday night maybe you could sleep
Tuesday night you couldn't sleep
Wednesday night you had to leave
Thursday morning and then Friday you had
the radio so you had maybe two nights a
week and I didn't respect sweet
I did not respect sleep you just don't
when you're young you're like [__] it
I'll sleep when I'm dead you know and
that's hey man I ain't mad at you I
ain't [__] mad at you but
you have no idea how much it weighs on
you not to mention the alcohol
the rifa the Edibles a family you know
as I got older I couldn't deal with
everything and listen there was a lot of
my [__] plate guys
but that's the differences I see that my
mind
comedy-wise during the week is dead when
Lee comes around my mind wakes the [__]
up we crack some fantastic jokes this
week we talked about snorting shoe
polish and [__] you know making a
shirt for Jewish people uh shoes with
parachutes yeah because if you live in
Israel and Palestine throws a bomb on
you you're up in the air you don't die
from the flight you die from the land
but if they bomb you you [__] and
you're up there like the guy from
wakanda forever with your little [__]
heels flapping around I'm looking for
those [__] shoes those are the shoes
I'm looking for so we're gonna invent
the new Jewish shoe yeah it's going to
call Jewish pride and these [__]
shoes have parachutes and something else
we we were gonna have a yamaka with a
propeller too a yamaka with a propeller
so that saves you a little [__] as
soon as you hit the bomb you put the
safety element
Friday night we were throwing some heat
in this [__] basement talking about
drugs and we're gonna make a new shirt
Jewish power yeah Jew power Jew power
and sell them because that's big we
gotta [__] you know yeah another [__]
Kanye another one with Kanye and the
great wall and the Egyptians is stepping
on them and [__] or Palestine whatever
the [__] they are I don't know all of it
I don't know we were [__] throw in
heat put them in the merch line yeah but
my mind doesn't get like that am I
forgetful
yes and no I gotta be honest with you
yes and no if I tell you I'm going to
call you back
you know you and you remember but you
remember six hours late you remember
when you look at your phone and go [__]
he asked me for a size I gotta call him
back at seven eleven hours ago
that kind of [__] but no I'm tired you
know my knees
listen man when I
I've accepted you accept it after a
while
you have to do the math in your head oh
my knee feels weird it's a 50 year old
knee
55 years old what do you think it's
supposed to feel like when you were
eight no it said so I I understand all
those functions right but then on the
other like like you're saying you're
taking taking better care of yourself
like you're a lot wiser now I'm not
calling you well but you know you you're
better prepared you can like you can do
different things that you couldn't do at
30 or 40.
listen man you lose little things but
you work with with what you got
you know I was very discouraged from
even going to jujitsu
and the most motivational Jiu Jitsu guy
looked at him and it's John jock he's
missing fingers from birth
and he didn't quit he went in there and
said I got to make it work for me
and that's very impressive so did
anybody see the last Rambo
it's very violent the last Rambo he made
it was the end of the Rambo series and
it was very violent and when you watch
that movie you see a gentleman that's
old
so he knows he can't hand the hand
combat you
he knows he's going to get beat up so he
has to outweigh you with his mind he put
grenades and he put the doors one and
one you know he put music for him and he
shot arrows he kept everybody at his
distance but he worked from his
strengths and that's what you could do
but that's what you could do throughout
your whole life because we're not all a
hundred percent
so why not look at your weaknesses
accept them and go okay my strengths
have to overpower my weaknesses I'm
still going to work on my weaknesses but
I got this strength let's work with what
we have
I was thinking about this on the drive
up yesterday
because that my cousin called me and he
he's moving back from LA to the East
Coast
and I was thinking about it because I
hate like when you have like a decision
like that to make like should I move
back should I switch jobs should I break
up with somebody should I like a good
life decision like that I don't I it
freaks me out and I don't know I don't
know how to make that pick and like look
at my weaknesses and my strengths like
and I was thinking about like your
birthday you must look back at like
decisions you've made throughout your
life like how like and you don't seem to
have that problem making decisions
because I made a lot of bad ones
[Music]
when you've been making bad decisions
all your life
eventually
you hang in there you start making good
ones you know we all make bad [__]
decisions and the younger we are we make
the worst decisions we make the worst
ones we don't know
but you know the one thing I read when I
reread the book when I wrote with Erica
I read about how many times I started
and it was it got me a little bummed up
you know I would start over like I would
pick up my dang and move across town and
start with this a clean slate why would
that bum you out
it never really bummed me out that much
because I would [__] up
so I was forced to learn how to pick up
the pieces all my life you know when you
keep [__] up it's like a [__]
nightmare
and after a while you're like I can't do
this no more it's not that you get wiser
or smarter you're like I cannot keep
doing this anymore I can't keep dropping
my phone I can't keep going back to this
[__] girl it's just ruining my life
you just pick yourself up and the more
you do that you start getting confidence
in your decisions
and all your decisions now you know it's
like when we talk about comedy
I I love comparing comedy to life
because we've always said that there's
great joke writers
and I I bet you it happens with music
you know musicians especially writers
you what we talking about about uh to
sit making decisions you
let me see what the [__] when you go up
on stage you have these jokes that you
write um
and sometimes you go up there
I was I was talking to one of the guys
from patreon and he said he went to do
his show but they were all yuppies and
he opted out you lost
you lost because you judge the audience
and when you're a young comic you go up
on stage and you have this joke you want
to do and it's [__] dirty and you
want to rock their world but then you
look over and you see a [__] Grandpa
right with white hair and white and his
and his wife's got white hair and
they're drinking water and you're like
you know what
I'm gonna crack this joke but I'm gonna
crack it scared
it's like when you throw a rock and you
duck you could throw a rock two ways you
could throw when you watch those
Palestinians throw rocks they don't
throw rocks scared they take the Rock
and they go [__] you Alibaba but if you
pick up the Rock and throw it like with
your head up
it's not gonna go right same thing
happens for a joke you gotta stand
behind that Joe
it's this is not a punch and it hurts
more than a punch it hurts more than a
[__] punch to be I rather get punched
in the face when you have those specific
jokes that you want to crack and you
crack them and it's a good joke but
guess what [__] you're not standing
behind your joke if you want to learn
how to stand behind your jokes you watch
a man named Doug stano he'll teach you
what I'm talking about but it's the same
in life you have to stand behind your
decisions so the only way you can be
confident about a [__] decision
is if you've done it before or been in
this situation right you know when we
were moving here I was I wasn't worried
about them this is the first time I had
to bring two other [__] civilians
with me this wasn't this wasn't the Joey
show of late where I just said I only 2
000 I owe Mike ten thousand it's time to
leave time and I just left those days
are over because I got cargo now
so that was a lot of pressure to move
here because what if I let her down and
what if I let the kid down what if the
kid was more but I'm like this is Jersey
and I have faith in the neighborhood Pro
and it's not the neighborhoods that I
grew up in
that Community is still in there so I
made a good choice was it a good choice
for me do I feel the same way I did in
La no I've had a I've struggled here the
last two and a half years but I'm
getting better I I struggled mentally
because decisions
decisions same thing we were talking
about you know I love stand-up comedy
but I got no urge to get in the [__]
car and go do a spot
you can't do a spot for free why go
commit to a paid spot so I know that
I [__] know these things but to get
back to you it's the same thing in life
man when you say [__] you you got to
stand behind it if you if you're arguing
with your girlfriend you're like that's
it we're done I'm never gonna call you
again you call it three days later right
you defeated the [__] the whole
Patois the whole goddamn thing you know
and but then like that's the hard part
for me is like
still like when I think of what stand by
your decision means it's like you're
like okay this is like this is it and
this is why I'm doing it but my brain
once I make a decision my brain will
come up and start [__] with you what
about this way and yeah it's like man
it's time to read the Stephen cutting
book again about the war of art yeah or
The Art of War whatever not the zunzoo
one right because it's that it's getting
that stupid listen
the reason why I was struggling
I would struggle the last couple months
is because there were days I could go to
Jujitsu and I wouldn't
because I will let my fears I would go
wow I'm gonna go there and I'm gonna
breathe and I'm not going to be able to
breathe and then tomorrow I'm going to
be sore and I wouldn't go and guys at
one o'clock
I'd be [__] furious at myself no you
didn't go but it goes back to anything I
ever did before
I remember one time I was doing comedy
maybe four years
and I did something and left with a girl
from a comedy thing and it was no big
deal it was an open mic I wasn't getting
paid you know
that bothered me
for a long time
I'd rather go up there and bomb than not
do the [__] spot
right
I'd rather go up there and bomb than not
do a spot and not know
not know what could have happened you
know what I'm saying it's like you going
with your electric guitar you're going
to go play Nirvana and you get that
there's a bunch of cowboys and you're
like God damn it I don't have my
Johnny's I don't have my Johnny Cash hat
you know what I'm saying it panicked
[__] but go back Blues Brothers 1982.
they walked into the bar they opened up
playing
whatever the [__] it was the people
started throwing bottles at him and [__]
they turned the lights off they
regrouped and they sang rawhide
they figured it the [__] out and then
they won them over the guy's like that's
the best show we've ever seen and that
was the blue she had the Whip and [__]
he's pumped it yeah the chick is smoking
the cigarette and it knocks it out of
her hand all that stuff
like you know it's a commitment when you
make those type of decisions you have to
make a commitment to yourself
and go it's all going to work out
and then did you
ever run into a situation like that
again where like you were thinking about
not going up always every [__] time
I went to do comedy
I would in the hotel room on Saturday I
would figure out
how can I slip on a banana peel and not
do this [__] show
you know you always have that fear in
you but if you let that fear win
then you're done you're never going to
get nowhere in your life you just got to
close your eyes and go I'm gonna do this
and do it and the more you keep doing
that to yourself you're getting the
in this in the thing of [__] listen
one of the best anecdotes I ever heard
was on that [__] show with the Lakers
on HBO oh yeah they were driving back
with his daughter and she was asking a
question he goes you see that plane
right there
because a lot of people don't notice
that when a plane starts to go down they
shut the engines off and it's just free
fall so some [__] like that but they
couldn't sell a lot of tickets if they
told the the audience that the consumer
that right he goes it's the same thing
in [__] life
if you don't fly you're never gonna fall
well
so if you don't go for it and guys there
was nobody listen man it took me
February of 89 to July to July of 91 to
get on stage
let's look at that that's a year right
that's 18 months that's almost two years
from what I kept telling people I'm
gonna do comedy I'm just writing
material I'm right that writing that's
[__] that's why I tell people stop
writing you're never gonna write just go
up there
get it over with
it go up there and sing a song I don't
give a [__] what you do go up there and
tell a story they're gonna boo you
anyway but I want you to get it out of
the way and I want you to realize that
even with all the booze you've never
done anything like this in your life
right even with all the booze in the
room you're never gonna feel like this
in all your life I give you 10 blow jobs
and put a firecracker in your [__]
you're never gonna feel like this the
feeling you're gonna get from doing that
stand up and bombing
is but any feeling you've had you might
feel a little creeped out but it's like
getting smacked in the face for the
first time you walk away and go what the
[__] was that did I just allow that to
happen I'm going back tomorrow night
it's the same [__] thing and like
especially with open mics if you like
people usually if you just say it's my
first time like as crazy as open mikers
can be they love it they're very we're
very supportive at least for the
beginning eventually if you're bad we'll
make fun of you but the first couple
times it's like and I I tell the story
every time someone is not sure about an
open mic I did open mics at the library
on Sunset and there was a legit homeless
guy with bags like not just a guy living
in his car like a legit homeless guy who
would do it before me and did better
than I would he would it was funnier
than I was like homeless people do open
legs you can do an open mic
open mics are a slash between mental
health
like if you check bracelets at an open
mic you'll catch one guy that just got
out of the insane asylum oh yeah like
that afternoon or the day before or a
halfway house and like listen man it's
the first step to get healthy listen
there's a lot of people go up on stage
and say some crazy [__] yeah but
eventually they don't see how people
react to it and they start coming around
they start coming around because they
know they're not winning this war and
there's guys that just show up on
Mondays I love those guys
they don't want nothing out of life
they don't want nothing you talk to them
after and they're like [__] you I'm
going back to my job I work at Subway
I'm having a great life and you're like
okay but and but they show up every
Monday
they don't want to go on the road they
don't want to be a big deal and it's
great to see those lunatics they come in
with a handcuff on
you know they all come in a little crazy
but you know it means some I went to jiu
jitsu today I could tell there was a
brand new kid in there
and he had to be 100 pounds overweight
and he was running and I'm like look at
this guy in the middle of the circle
because you can't run I run in the
middle I'm not fast enough so I run the
middle I just do a light Jog and I'm
like it takes a lot of Courage for this
guy and after class I want him to I'm
like oh bro keep coming back don't let
this
you'll be you're gonna melt through that
[__] fat in a month or two
just keep coming back and I love it I
love when somebody you're right when
somebody comes in and they go up on
stage I'll do for the first time I go
out of my way
to make that version because when I got
on stage the first time a lot of
[__] went out of their way for
me dog
a lot of [__] were like hey man
thank you for coming down hey man keep
coming back one guy told me because you
sucked on stage but your [__] stage
presence was brilliant keep coming back
amen [__] yeah I'm gonna come back don't
worry about it I just got to figure out
how to get rid of this [__] loose
around my neck and ex-wife
[Music]
but I'm coming back don't worry about it
and that's the thing you have to look at
everything listen guys you're not gonna
like everything
you're not gonna like everything you try
there's no way you might go to El Nido
and go I don't like this steak Joey
that's fine but you like to steak from
somewhere you know whatever you might
try hockey but that's okay give it a
fair chance
and if not my daughter quit wrestling
it upset me for two minutes
because when she came to me she came to
me proper
came to me and gave me an explanation
she goes you know I go to Jujitsu and
you go you know I don't miss a class but
Dad didn't like it she goes the boys are
a little rougher on me and I didn't know
what to do she goes if I would have
known what to do I would have wrestle
them so I saw the Jiu Jitsu coach I saw
the wrestling coach at jujitsu
Friday and he goes your daughter didn't
come back I go you know why they do a
court class here at jiu jitsu because
it's not
it's not uh yo you don't roll you just
drill you just drill you learn to move
you drill it 10 times and you and let me
tell you something the first five of
those classes that you go over there at
Alice you're gonna be sweating during
those drills you're gonna go what the
[__] and that's going to make you come
back and then they don't if you don't
want a roll long roll we just want you
to learn the system correctly so you get
confidence Mercy didn't have confidence
so she goes what I want to do is start
going on Wednesday nights at the
basketball to that place because they
teach you from scratch fine
I could dig with that she stuck baseball
she stuck with basketball she stuck with
the drums till the end of class this
year she told me that I don't like the
drums I don't like how they play them
there they play like you know yeah she
don't want to do that she wants to play
in The Rolling Stones you know so it's
hard to do something when you're not
good at it that's one of my my biggest
uh weaknesses is if I'm not good at
something I'm it's very hard for me to
try to do it yeah but let's take them
back to the conversation nobody tries to
an open mic on a Lamborghini right so
when you try something for the first
time you're not going to be good at it
if you think something out like last
night we were surprised we went bowling
I have not bowled
20 years since Houston night we used to
go to midnight bowling after the gigs
and eat brownies that'd be a heavy metal
band [__] lights and [__] tremendous
I have them both so when I went there
last night there was no expectations but
also night grew a strike yeah and I'm
like okay I still you know how to get
back to the first two or terrible I
thought my arm was going to fall out I
thought my knee was going to connect the
shoes were slippery
but you go back there and you and you
did it I didn't expect that my
expectations were low right your
expectations are low I didn't expect you
know to sell out the boat you know to
throw 10 strikes I threw one or two I'm
like okay now I got it I might go back I
might go back and start bowling again in
a league on a Monday night why not I'm
at that age if this is what it's all
about you take the witch off a joint and
you go you're not going to be good at
everything guys anything
the first time you did it but there's a
difference and I think bowling is
similar to stand up because you and
usually at your first couple open mics
you'll get a laugh or a chuckle at least
am I I'm not you're not gonna get not
gonna get a standing ovation but like I
I think I got at least two or three I've
never I've rolled with those big balls
like three times in my life where I grew
up it was all candlepins so I don't know
how to bowl
but I when like when I got a couple pins
I was like oh [__]
I can understand like but I think the
difference maybe with mercy and I don't
know she's tough so maybe she probably
did but like if you're getting like
not beat up but if you're getting
constantly pinned in in wrestling and
not seeing any Improvement I could see
her being like yeah
you know she didn't I don't think she
just wanted to learn the fundamentals
and they taught him real quick and like
she went to Tupac and like you're
wrestling on Saturday she's like no I'm
not always like a match yeah oh Jesus
yeah she's like no man no she wanted to
learn the basics she's I'm the same way
I'm the same [__] way I don't want to
go in there until I learned [__] that's
why I took a stand-up comedy class
for 31 dollars in Boulder and then when
I got a little
into it when I came here two years later
I took another eight week class
because I don't know everything
nobody knows everything
I feel better like when I lift weights
you know what 20 years ago I go into a
gym
I didn't give a [__]
now I don't want to live by myself
I'll pay you Mike just to watch my form
because I don't want to get hurt and
then I can't do anything
so I'd rather give you the half a yard
and we live together and you just watch
my form and tell me Joe you're not doing
that joy joy put that weight down Joey
you're gonna have my [__] put that
down yeah I want you back here on
Wednesday you following me there's a lot
of things I'll do at my age now but I
can do by myself
but there's a couple things like lifting
and all that Jiu Jitsu is a lot of the
people in the room
I hear it all the time Joey breathe oh
really one of the old guys from the
other side I'll go Joey I see your face
you're getting red breed you [__]
but you know when I went into for jiu
jitsu I didn't [__]
I was like what the [__] the first time
I did a hip Escape I thought my world
was gonna end
and then they wanted you to do 30 yards
of them and I remember getting them
going I'm gonna [__] die remember
that kettlebell class we used to go yeah
I thought we were gonna [__] die in
that class that was not a good
kettlebell class that knucklehead
but but then we went to the Irish dude
in the Bronx and he was the real deal
Holyfield you went in there you knocked
it out in 20 minutes and you went home
and he taught it the right way he taught
you from [__] scratch he did the
remember he'd make you bend over and
teach you that's what I like I like that
and I think there's a difference because
I was trying to think of the difference
between the two classes and like there's
confidence and then there's like um
bravado is the right word but like
arrogance and like you can be confident
in your stuff but if your overconfidence
is a bad thing too like you don't have
to like do the most or or do this the
biggest weight like we didn't like Irish
didn't care what weight we were using no
no he just wanted you to show up and do
it by the time remember he would time
you put the form the form he put the
[__] workout on the board for you and
[__] you did it on your own there were
other people in there and he was in
there and he would watch he'd put me in
the corner with the chubby [__] there
was one guy there that was [__]
strong and when guy with the beard there
was some strong [__] old
strength gym it wasn't like uh you know
let's let's drink a smoothie it was a
[__]
hypo [__] B TRX yeah and kettlebells
but to get back to you listen man we're
not good at that Mike when you came here
and we did the videos
you figured it out
you didn't take a video editing class or
a [__] you didn't go to NYU or
nothing like that we figure it out first
couple weeks is a little scary like
anything else in life
it's like what the [__] am I doing but
then you figure it out and you
you do a couple things and now you start
picking up confidence and you go holy
[__] I did that with what I read there
can you imagine if I really put my mind
into this and there you go
you're not going to be good at
everything guys I still regret quitting
the base when I was a kid
I love Rhythm and all that [__] I just
the bass player just stands there
like a [__] good look but then five
years later Rudy sarso showed up Ozzy
and I'm like oh [__]
[Music]
oh [__] he's coming May 3rd we're all
gone yeah we're all going to see Rudy
size that's performing yeah MJ pack up
the corner here oh awesome
what like what else
because I mean you were saying like it's
just a number but you're right I think
every 10 like those 10 and fives are
like big like what else does like 60
have you think about
it really had me thinking about
where I've been like where did these
years go
I had to break it down to be honest with
you I broke it down into
44 years without my mother
all right I broke it down into that not
to be a [__] [__] but just I had
him yeah I had it and in 44 years what
the [__] have I accomplished in 14 44
years what did I do in 44 years you know
forget about the failures I can't count
all those [__] but you could
count a couple of little
things that meant a lot to you you know
so
it was great I do listen man
I never wanted to go to prison and it
was very embarrassing
but if that's what made me into a man I
guess I'll do it again
if all those little failures built me up
to here
I have no regrets about them you really
don't because they worked obviously
something worked dog I'm still pissed I
didn't join the Army over a [__]
blood test
over a blood test
over a [__] blood test right now I
would have been getting four grand a
month [__] from the with full
insurance for the rest of my life I
would have been on it for the last 20
years
and I still couldn't understand them
well if I would have been in the Army it
would have been like prison I would have
still been cracking jokes in the Army
right and one of those [__] guys
would have said you should be a stand-up
when you get out of here like uh Gary
home was in the Navy when he started
standing yeah
yeah I guess
and I would have been getting four grand
a month plus [__] insurance and I
could do what the [__] I want to do so
who I [__] up
I [__] up if you were you listen to
the Army right now the the services
they [__] missed their
annual quota quota by 60
Cent
yeah this woke Society is not joining up
and this wokes out of all the societies
that need the [__] military it's this
one I'm seeing kids that are 21 that
have no muscle in their body at all
they've been working on Z boxes whatever
the [__] that is Xbox Zeba I don't know
uh you know they've been doing that for
20 [__] years in college yeah there's
a lot more of those kids than what they
are athletes like build kids moms are
taking kids out of football
after what I've seen the last couple
years
it's real CTE is real so there's a
degree of what you want to do especially
at an early age you know especially
early age so we're taking you know right
now the most hated thing in our society
is toxic masculinity
people want to hate that but they don't
know that we're not toxic masculinity if
we didn't have toxic masculinity we
would have been [__] slaves to the
Russians and the Chinese 200 years ago
200 years ago because you need a cup as
bad as he was as bad as a person as he
was I'm not you needed Christopher
Columbus to balance out [__] in life you
need Genghis Khan's and it just happens
I'm not you know
but think about it what we talking about
about it
you were talking about like people hate
toxic masculinity yeah they hate
toxicity
so right now what do we need in this
country more on everything we need
strong men
we need strong men you re you watch
what's going on with men the numbers
testosterone is going down in young men
I mean it's just going down
listen
I went up and down in my life I'm not
proud of having a little bit of toxic
masculinity
but Jesus Christ I was born with two
balls and a [__] what else do you want
me to act like you want me to walk
around with a tennis racket and you know
I mean think about it guys God blessed
us with two balls and a [__] [__] and
on the other side he made women that are
[__] beautiful objects beautiful
objects for what they are
you know there's some people I'm not
saying men have to throw men out the
window to survive
but sometimes you need some men to lead
other men
some people are [__] lost in life I
was lost for a long time all these old
people that I dropped their names
growing up they would [__] influence
me they influenced me with a word or an
action or something to that effect
but right now for you not to join the
Army the way the world is going
if you're a real [__] American
are you [__] [__] are you [__]
idiot the Army needs young men more and
listen the young men need the Army more
than they've ever [__] needed because
I don't know if you checked man shit's
getting rough out there yeah shit's
getting rough and competitive they're
talking about why are kids going to
college bro what we're in a [__]
standstill right now you know you're
gonna drop 300 000 for college education
and be on a job search for two years of
your life nobody's going to learn the
trades the Army needs [__] Savages
more than ever now you can write your
own ticket you could pay for college you
could do so much who gives a [__] that
you give yourself for 20 years you're
going to give yourself to some [__]
anyway
you're gonna give yourself to some
[__] company that don't give a [__]
about you anyway these [__]
don't give a [__] about you but guess
what if you do the job you're supposed
to do you're gonna travel the world
which you would have never done on your
own or with credit cards yeah under
somebody else's umbrella but you're
still [__] traveling and in 20 years
when you're 38 years old
when everybody else is just getting
warmed up you're walking around with
four thousand a month Insurance out the
[__] Gazoo
benefits out the Gazoo and they'll pay
for you for a master's [__] degree
now 20 30 40 years ago when I was 18 I
blew off the [__] blood test
there were more options for 18 year olds
obviously I jumped on one of the options
but today there ain't that many [__]
options guys but could they do you think
they could because I'm not even gonna
put it on the kids today I'll put it on
myself me at 18
I I think I would have lasted 30 minutes
I don't think I would have made it
through the haircut of Basics
I don't think I'm like could they turn
if if people were signing up could they
turn them into soldiers I don't think I
could be a soldier and like in a million
lifetimes what's a soldier
what's a soldier what's the big thing
about being a soldier some soldiers kill
some soldiers work on computers
some soldiers Drive tax some soldiers
become medics
so there's different qualifications for
being that you know listen man how the
[__] is the Army off by 50 or something
one of those I saw this maybe a month
ago or two that they're really you know
because we're woke
we're very [__] woke you know and we
I don't know I don't know what it is but
I see the shape of some of these young
men and I'll tell you man
I didn't have a lot going for me at 18
through 21.
but I did have something going for me I
had balls
and I took chances and I didn't give a
[__] about picking up a phone and I
didn't give a [__] about walking up to a
job site and going hey man you need a
laborer uh no come back in a month how
about I work for a week for free and
prove to you how [__] good I am and
if you don't like me after a week you
know you have to [__] pay me you
think people do that today
no yeah so like you I think you could
have been
molded I guess I don't know if that's
the right word but you know I think they
could have made you into a soldier
absolutely
absolutely because I always wanted to
shoot somebody so it would have been
easy yeah it would have been easier for
me to become a soldier because now I
could shoot people with 200 other white
dudes I'm in
I'm in we're all gonna shoot you at once
with little helmets on this [__] [__]
yeah
you know I would have learned to jump
out of helicopter I mean listen man you
go up there and you think about it
you're sitting there with eight of the
guys guess what the biggest guy with all
the muscles and veins he's more scared
than you are
with all those muscles and veins he's
just as scared as you are he's talking I
can't wait to get up to 8 000 feet but
now when he gets up there he's trapped
he's [__] trapped he got a jump he
been talking [__] with those muscles and
here you are just as scared and it's
like anything else
the guy looks he and goes one two three
and he throws you off or whatever the
[__] they do and I guarantee three
seconds into it you're like holy [__]
I'm happy I got a [__] New Jersey
holy [__] I'm happy I got out of Iowa
[__] them bunks holy [__] I'm happy I
got out of Seattle [__] Kurt Cobain and
Pearl Jam I think it's as soon as the
parachute opens you look at me okay yeah
and either you want to do it again
wait a second
can I talk to you you mean to tell me I
could jump out of a plane land this
shoot a [__] yeah
800 a [__] year you know you ain't
gonna make no money he ain't gonna make
no money but that's the truth that's how
you become a soldier
so you know I I think that we could all
they could all molded you listen for
it's like Jiu Jitsu it's like anything
else 10 people going seven people come
out
and they depend on those three people
rotating are you allowed to quit the
Army once you sign up I think you could
come up with something you're scared of
the dark you know you join the Army yeah
into the dark you know they allow
transgenders now right they allow
transgenders they allow gays in the
military they allow everything in the
military and what the [__] are you doing
at home with two balls and a dick
between your legs watching TV thinking
about going to Technical College lines
lying to yourself now who didn't lie to
mice I lied to myself I'm gonna be a I'm
gonna be a chef I'm gonna be a painter
I'm gonna be this I'm gonna be that look
I ended up a [__] [__] at a comic so
obviously so yeah what the [__] guys go
For Broke I mean I I would join the Army
today if I could
I would definitely [__] try it not
now at 60. I'm not jumping out of a
plane but 18 what the [__] did I have to
lose at 18.
what the [__] do I need you
[__] have to lose at 18 19 or
20.
nothing
it seems um and 20 years seems like a
long time in 18. that's a lot yeah but
how old are you right now yeah I'm 34
and that's now looking back out you're
like how many years ago did you quit
college
um let's see 12.
the four years of college is 16.
I I'd be four years away right now you'd
be four years away
and they probably got a program that
they'll let you out in 38 you take 10
less and then you go to [__] one of
those International countries and work
security because they're gonna give you
another 300 000 a year plus the pension
you're [__] getting because I'm here
with all these people that that they can
pre they get knowledge with 38 37 years
now because they take a pay in their
pension but they go get another job for
300 000 a year working Security in Iraq
[__] Iran whatever [__] and uh you
know so there's so many opportunities
for you so think about it
[Music]
I'm just telling you for the guy at home
that's sitting there scratching his head
going uh listen to 2000 podcasts and I'm
still not funny well you know what I
don't know what to tell you it's not
gonna work out like that you got to get
on stage and make it work for you I've
been doing my podcast for 20 years and I
got 12 listeners then time to join the
army they got a podcast program in there
they'll rock your [__] world in the
Army you know
that's just me here guys talking I know
that's what I would do in today's world
if I didn't have a high school diploma
if I was struggling if I was just going
to go out in the workplace
to make the small 15 an hour and
struggle the rest of my life
I'm gonna maybe get a job for two years
maybe get myself the good thing now is
you have these night courses
you can take computer courses online I
don't know how expensive that is they
dude they have stuff like Harvard like
like Ivy League schools but not not the
entire uh curriculum but they'll have
classes on there for free for free
you look incredible you can do the class
what kind of classes uh I saw some
coding ones they I like I I don't I
didn't even really look fully into I'm
sure they have history and they have
there's stuff you can find every and and
even on top of that like I looked at
I I took a
a commercial acting class I've never
taken like an actual acting class
I've never taken like a I didn't take a
stand-up class but I I've never even
taken like storytelling and you can take
stuff I don't know how good they are but
if you learn one or two things for a
couple hundred bucks
you know it's funny when you take those
classes
people I get a lot of emails from people
hey I heard you talk about this guy and
he's teaching a comedy class in
Minneapolis or something
I've spoken to a lot of people like that
and listen man there was a time
honestly when I thought those things
were a scam I really have to be honest
with you guys but
over time I learned something that
everybody has their own definition for
the artist stand-up comedy
and in eight weeks if you take a class
that's three hours a week and maybe they
give you a little homework they make you
watch Comedy whatever guess what
I'm not taught I don't want you to pay
ten thousand for a comedy class I don't
give a [__]
if [__] Chappelle's teaching with
Phyllis Dilla and [__] you know and
Jerry Seinfeld I'm not paying you ten
thousand dollars
but I will give you a couple hundred if
I'm serious about this career
because if I take one thing from the
class they're gonna teach eight weeks
and that's eight things you should take
from the class but forget about that if
I could take one thing from the class
who's worth my money if I take that and
apply it to the rest of my career that
thing that he talked about it's worth it
and then when you as you grow in the
in whatever field you're picking
you know I can't imagine being like a
mediocre guitar player
and a band picks you up okay and you're
like
I watched the
Molly Crew movie again the airline I
couldn't sleep one night that's one of
my favorite Rock movies and they had
that original guitarist at first and
then uh Mick came in and threw the guy
out I don't know if it's a a real story
or not but I guess I bet that happens a
lot where a guy comes in he's a medium
guitar player if you got a cool lead
he'll take you in this wing
you know I think I always think about
like uh the guy from Journey he was 16
in a band Neil Sean was in somebody's
band at 16 yeah Santana he was in
somebody's band that's 16. 16.
16 I'm going to give you a shot but I
guarantee if I take a 16 year old into
my band I'm gonna screw that
[__] and he's going to get
schooled by the bass player he's going
to get schooled by the drummer he's
going to take one thing from that band
even you know it's just I think about
those things that was oh little Stevie
Winwood when he sang with traffic I
think it was trapped
not trap and it doesn't matter yeah
traffic doesn't matter you know he was
16. little Stevie Winwood 15-14 Stevie
Wonder was little Stevie Wonder You know
when you go into those places everything
gets removed you're not a kid no more
you're one of me
We're Not Kids and I'm not an old man
you gravitated to me because I'm an old
man but we're an equal and I will take
into my wing and you know you see it all
the time when you watch old live concert
videos you know you see guitarists
looking at each other and they wink or
whatever you know take a breather I know
you can't play this lead I think you
know that's so funny yeah but like do
you think maybe
to take it back to like the Army thing
maybe that's why some people aren't
signing up for it like there's just
there are a lot more options now like
maybe people who are going to join the
Army are doing UFC stuff now like
there's like like any but there is
something that you could like everyone
could find something that like their
passionate about listen the Army isn't
for everybody and I was insane I know I
know that I'm just saying in today's
world that the Army's light it's not a
bad idea to join if you're young and you
have nothing going on
I think this listen I failed at 20
things early huh I wasn't good at any of
it but
let's get down to Basics here eventually
I found it I lucked out I was one of the
very fortunate that I found what I loved
and I pursued it for as long as I could
only drunk in the army or go to college
doesn't mean you're going to fail I
never said that no I've never said that
in my life you're not gonna fail
but I'd rather you be a little bit more
prepared
you might you know you might start as a
roofer work yourself up to a [__]
team captain that had roof for six years
and now the world's the limit
and I saw that with the car business
I saw people walking from the car
business from working at McDonald's
and they just got a niche for selling
they did it professionally and they make
six figures a year with no high school
diploma and they build on that
anything could be done bro you control
your own [__] Destiny if you want to
eat dog food you eat dog food if you
want to eat lobster tails you eat
lobster tails it's all your decision
what the [__] you want to do I mean it
really is
it's you saying how much of this [__]
can I take
and how far like how much you're willing
to try because do you think sometimes
like if people don't find not matching
everyone's gonna find it but if
someone's stuck if someone's listening
to or watching this and feels stuck are
they not trying did they not try enough
you [__] start every day
you know I quit snorting coke in 2007
but I started in 2003.
so for four years that's the last time
I'm gonna do blow I'm gonna go the right
way I'm gonna do this
it was just verbal diarrhea and I knew
it you don't think I knew it I was
saying it you know I know it guys but
again we're back to the situation of how
many times can you get kicked in the
balls
how many times can you end up homeless
how many times can you end up in jail
how many times do you end up doing
what's the what's the definition of
insanity
doing something over and over again yeah
expecting different results
right there
after the third strike you're like I
gotta figure it out and trust me I've
stuck around for nine strikes I've stuck
around for deep deep failure but how
long that's what you say to yourself
you know what man I can't eat another
potato sandwich it's time for me to get
a [__] job and get my life together
you know what I shouldn't be sleeping in
my sister's basement
you know it's time for me to get a
[__] job you know uh yeah there's
tons of rehabs you'd go to get help no
better rehab than you [__] waking up
in a hospital room you know Nikki Sixx
OD died brought him back went home and
shot up again
and that time passed out blood came out
of his arm he woke up and he goes no I'm
going to [__] rehab with the rest of
Motley Crue and they went on to do like
two or three great [__] albums after
that he killed the [__] guy in the
guitar you know whatever the singer from
whatever the [__] name is I get all
emotional here but it's true it's how
long am I going to continue to take this
how long am I going to continue to wake
up every morning with no money in my
pocket because I spent every dime on
cocaine last night and now I'll tell
Terry that the check got lost that
they're gonna send me another check
after a while she's gonna go with Joey
how many checks are you gonna lose
that's why after a year of dating that
she started going through the gigs with
me and she would take the check from the
promoter because she's like these checks
don't make it home right
if you understand me so how many times
it's up to you and how many times you're
going to tolerate this lifestyle before
you go you know what
I'm moving on to the next [__] Avenue
she's going he's going the dog is going
my mother's going I'm going for it
that's what motivates that's what got it
to me it wasn't a specific word it
wasn't a specific [__] situation it
was how long can you sleep on this
[__] stinky pillow
you know I used to have a blanket I
bought in 1984.
I put it at Walmart for 20 bucks it was
like a tiger that it was the same
blanket that I let the guy on fire the
homeless guy it was like polyester or
something you could tell those blankets
you're like man if somebody smokes a
joint I'm busting into flames
I bought that [__] blanket in 1984.
I had that blank erode
I had that blanket
Jesus and that was the only blanket I
had and it smelled so bad guys you wanna
watch it
I'd wash it once a year I didn't even
know you washed the [__] blanket I
don't even know where to start but I
remember that that blanket being in the
back of my car when I was living in my
car
before my apartment got towed my nice
little condo somebody lost a blanket
that's when I lost that blanket I
thought about that blanket a couple
nights ago I still remember going
what am I going to get my I still
remember sleeping with that blanket on
on Vista having that blanket over me and
the bat in the front of the car with the
sunroof up and jerking off you know how
many times I jerked off on that blanket
that's why I smell because there must
have been a thousand ghosts in that
[__] blanket it was just a ghost by
it smelled like come come sweat reefer a
little crunchy and I still remember
jerking off in that blank and [__] in
it and going like
how many times can I come on this
blanket like this blanket this tiger
should be pregnant by now how many
[__] like when am I gonna get a new
[__] blanket
and that's when the car got towed and I
ended up getting a new blanket but my
point is that
it's [__] like that that's the [__] that
you should you know and then I'll tell
you what really bothers me it's when you
[__] yourself over is one thing
but you really got to get your life
together when you start carrying over to
somebody else's life
and you're [__] over their life like
when I first met Terry
and we'll get to that situation some
other time you know because you care
about that person now you're like I
can't do that to that like when I met
Tyra I made a decision I can't carry her
over into my problems she can't handle
it she's not from that school she
doesn't understand that and I remember a
friend of mine came on one day and
accused me of robbing his watch
they [__] woke us up and I'm like you
come to my house for this [__] he was a
good friend of mine
he didn't like that I had a girlfriend
and he didn't and he didn't like that I
was rocking and rolling with comedy and
he wasn't so he took to like take me
down he came over I stopped talking to
that he found the watch of course he
accused me of it and then he started
worrying I'm like
dog I think your watch was missing oh I
found it in the toilet I'm sorry but you
never apologized to me you [__] lose
a [__] he's somewhere in Idaho
now telling people he's a producer he's
still [__] [__] him but yeah you just
get sick and tired of being sick and
tired and and that guy coming over and
Terry seeing that helped you realize
yeah I couldn't have her in my life I
still you know there was a time when
every afternoon about one o'clock three
times a week I would hit Terry up and go
hey
can you put 20 hours in my ATM account
I have eight dollars and then I want to
get a bag of reef for 20. how many times
I did that
a wife a girl she was named my wife at
the time
she was a girl I was dating
you know how many times I did that how
many times can you do that before you go
it's time I gotta get it [__]
together I'm asking my girlfriend for 20
bucks for weed
I I'm from the old school I'll give you
money to eat I'll pay for your rent
I'll put gas in your car but I shouldn't
be paying for your luxuries
I should never be paying for your
luxuries that's where you come in if I
take the time to cover your rent and bro
you can eat here and do whatever you
want but I can't start giving you wheat
money for cocaine now you're [__]
with me now now you're bringing me into
this so
that's when it becomes a problem and
that's when you got to go you know what
it's time to [__] strengthen my game
and I gotta do something with my [__]
life
and what do you think to close it out
like what do you think
was that final straw or was did you have
a bunch of final straws that like maybe
a bunch of them a bunch of them
you know yeah I was doing movies and I
was doing spots and I was opening up for
Rogan but I wasn't fulfilled
because I was doing coke and I just
couldn't reach my potential no I wasn't
fulfilled
I was sick of that I was sick of being a
horrible
I was sick of not having the ability to
earn money
because after a while I stopped like I
listened in L.A whenever I got into a
blind I sold an eight ball
I sold a couple eight balls I knew some
guys that were always looking I'd set
them up during the week hey man you got
to try this coke you know you know so I
I could always make a living but then
came a decision I couldn't do that no
more right and I stopped doing that I
still remember selling a pound of weed
to an agent
from Hackney agency he was my theatrical
agent I don't know if we get selling the
pound of weed and leaving then going one
of the cops gonna pull me out
like that's an undercover cop but I
needed the 200 like I really needed that
200 [__] dollars
I just decided I couldn't do all those
things no more that was it I was getting
to a different age I'm rocking and
rolling I'm friends with Joe I'm friends
with these other people and they're
gonna see my name in the paper for
selling a pound of weed the [__] an
agent
I need that in my [__] life no right
let's grab it down let's start from the
scratch let's work this a little harder
you know there was a point I quit stand
up
2009 I quit stand up
for how long
six months I just wow I was like I'm
just gonna uh work when Greg Garcia
calls me or one of my friends called me
I'll open up for Joe but I'll get a job
selling cars and then I failed a drug
test
brought you back in the podcast thing
came in yeah no and once a podcast world
came in I had a little bit more hope
because I could tell my story
and that what what is blowing my mind
right now is just like because you think
there's gonna be like one rock bottom or
one decision but it doesn't sound like
there is sounds like there's like one
decision that gets you this far and then
you have to make another decision and
like it's just like it's a like it's a
lot of small ones which is frustrating
because you think like I'm so close
maybe you always are that close
and it's just a decision away
think about it you're always that close
it's just a decision away you're always
that close it's just tightening that one
screw oh [__] I did that you know holy
[__] I didn't look at it from that
perspective maybe walking away from it
and attacking it back like I walked away
from Jiu Jitsu for two years I just I go
if I do this again this is how I'm gonna
have to do it
I gotta do it like this I gotta do it
this way do it this way I'll lift
weights I gotta eat this way I gotta
sleep this way so it gave me a chance
you never really fail
I never talked about backing up looking
at something and attacking it from a
different direction
but you got to make me a promise that
you attack it and go to that direction
people take a break from things to fall
back in love with things from time to
time
so yeah
that's basically it [__] we
gave you a little uh
I know it's a holiday today not a lot is
going on but
Lee came it's my 60th birthday Uncle
Mike's here we're making it happen to
show them those [__] shrooms to these
[__] Savages oh [__] look what's back
for today I mean we ate a bunch of them
over the weekend we went bowling last
night but we're gonna eat some more I
told Mike's like let's do the podcast
Monday and Mike these ain't gonna last
get your ass up here I want you to get a
taste of this [__] silly chocolate
[__] tremendous guys I got a bunch
sent to me so we got a little party
going for a few days and that's sitting
that that guy is another fun-filled
Monday podcast with my man Lisa Adam my
60th birthday at least celebrating the
birthday happy birthday happy birthday
thank you guys I love you stay black and
I'll see you [__] next Monday tip
top Magoo and now for a word for my
[__] responses all right I want
to thank you Savages thank you for
watching today I know it's a holiday and
a lot of you [__] at home so we
wanted to make it happen to you but
listen the joint is brought to you by
liquid IB one stick of liquid IV hydrate
two times faster than water and has five
essential essential vitamins use it the
first thing in the morning before a
workout or on a long flight I love the
concord grape that's my all-time
favorite I like the strawberry
I like the sour apple I think it's sour
apple but it's like green apple it's
[__] delicious they're all good
they're gluten-free dairy free and soy
free liquid IV contains three times the
electrolytes
of traditional sports drinks now grab
your liquid IV in bulk nationwide at
Costco or get 20 off when you go to
liquid iv.com use code Joey at checkout
j-o-e-y that's 20 off anything you order
when you shop better hydration today
using promo code Joey at liquid
iv.com the joint is also brought to you
by stamps.com stamps.com lets you print
your own Postage and shipping labels
right from your home office it'll be
ready to go in minutes I've been with
stamps for over 10 years and me and my
wife really enjoy them with stamps you
can easily schedule and pick up and
compare carriers rates with a click of a
button print postage whenever you do
business all you need is a computer and
a printer stamps even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get the party started now set your
business up for success I don't care if
it's small I don't care if it's huge
when you get started with stamps.com
that's what you're doing sign up with
promo code Joey for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code Joey
now another one of my favorites because
you [__] are using the ball
trimmer on your face I love it you sniff
that thing and it gives you power but
guess what manscape just announced a
brand new beard hedger it's cordless
it's waterproof and you can shave [__]
it anywhere and it gives you 20
different hand cutting links from Mr
Clean to Grizzly Adams who's better than
you nobody plus manscape is throwing in
that beard shampoo and conditioner
designed to moisturize reduce ingrown
hairs and replace the natural oils in
your bid impress your lady when you
finish it off with manscape beard oil
and beard pump went to Europe that bin
on her [__] and she loses her [__]
mind and since manscape wants you to
have all the tools for the job that's
thrown in a beard brush and comb and
scissors to make you look like Richard
Gere before the operation so get 20 off
and free shipping with code Diaz Diaz at
manscape.com that's 20 off in free
shipping at manscape.com use code Diaz
the only thing manscape I want to thank
stamps.com and I think I'm going to
thank liquid IV but most importantly I
want to thank you savages for having my
back Lee and Mike for stopping in today
and making it happen I love you as
[__] have a great week and I'll
see you next Sunday Tip Top magooie
Louie
thank you